we went to comic-con just a couple
months ago and showed a little bit of
the film and they did like a Marvel
class photo and I was pinching myself is
it like a bucket list type item for you
as an actor or is it just the next
project for you um it definitely is a
bucket list I feel like there's
something really special to it and you
feel really supported as an actor in
this and you know and they do films
really well I mean they have a perfect
track record so so it's great to be a
part of some of a legacy and out of all
these amazing films that you have done
prior to this one it just feels like to
me and I'm just assuming things maybe
but once you sign that contract to be in
a Marvel film you're at a different
level perhaps in your career is that
strange to say it I mean it it
definitely feels like you've been
invited to the party yeah I suppose
there's something of that in it I think
Tilda described it as being invited to
play in the circus know it's like you
know you're gonna go do a run an
exciting ride in adventure yeah they're
getting toured with Benedict now
Benedict is a very talented actor as we
all know but he also seems to have a
jokester side to him
is that a parent on on set yeah yeah he
keeps it very light and fun and he's got
that great British wit and you know
sense of humor that he kind of gets for
free but yeah I mean we had some really
intense you know emotional scenes and
and he always found the levity in it so
yeah it doesn't extend out from um I
mean he I'm trying to think whether
there's a great gag reel that's coming
out that shitin will show you that side
of Benedict better than I could probably
describe it and I'm assuming your mom
and your sister were like okay you're
working with Benedict can you get us on
set dad was that that all happen ladies
do like the Cumberbatch yes I mean a lot
of women were picking my brain about
about him so and he is everything you
hope for and more I'm sure you wanted to
know - he's great
why when I get excited but I know that
I'm gonna be speaking to so yeah it's
all good even men you know get excited
sure sure
man Cumberbitches - I can't say yeah can
I can you just did I did there it is you
play the surgeon a doctor did you do a
lot of research in terms of like
watching Clooney up there doing his
thing moves really any of these doctors
who passed on your list of like recent
researching um I well my mom was a nurse
growing up so I kind of got to watch her
up close and spent some time in
hospitals through her and then we had a
really great neurosurgeon on set with us
I spoke to a great neurosurgeon here in
Toronto and also in London I shadowed
someone at that st. Mary's Hospital
there so I just kind of hung out with
real doctors a lot suturing that I was
really nervous about and actions right
yeah so I wanted that to look really
work real so one of the doctors sent me
a video of he was suturing a broad
turkey breasts and so practice over the
Christmas break and that was it a real
person that you were suturing ever was
it like a cadaver oh it wouldn't hurt
anyone drink no no one was hurt in the
making of this film
yeah no bendix had like a special thick
fake chest on and so that I wouldn't
actually they didn't trust me to not
puncture his flesh what does that mean
oh I know that
I know it's all rubber and you jump let
you see triskin I'm telling you you're
right hugh jackman would've